l'espace réglée du bas de la rivière
s'est transformé le temps d'une journée
en territoire japonais ce sont les
élèves venus des établissements
scolaires du quartier se sont prêtés au
jeu du manga le manga bande dessinée
japonaise est très apprécié par les
jeunes démonstration avec quelques
collégiens du collège a réduit par kung
fu devant un signe un film attendu du
feu avec moi car c'est vrai alors ne fut
pas notre avis en famille des
amphétamines kawai
malheureusement pour mac à l est pas fou
amoureux
l'engouement pour ces personnages aux
noms étrangers qui vivent d épopée
extraordinaire se retrouve aussi dans
notre île c'est d'ailleurs pour cela que
la documentaliste du collège ridley a
voulu aller plus loin en créant un club
bonjour à tous je m'appelle contours
sont aussi des collèges où il aurait
volé une arrivée et je suis dessinateur
et conteur
c'est un père tout est basé sur le
volontariat
donc les élèves sont revenus tout tous
les jours on fait ce genre de repas
après leur repas à partir de 12h45 ont
réalisé l'exposition vous avez pu voir
c'est tintin et le kamishibaï et même
s'il est une manière même très éloignées
qui d'intéresser les enfants la lecture
le manga devient alors un support
incontournable car ces licences j'espère
sont devenus de vrais phénomènes de mode
et beaucoup de jeunes s'identifient au
personnage de ces bandes dessinées c'est
un manga de tite shônen
ça raconte l'histoire d'un jeune
magicien de dix ans le méné guise prime
fidh qui va en fait il va devoir
rattraper se dit avoir son diplôme de
magicien pour devenir vraiment un
magicien diplômés redire être au rayon
japon pour
avoir son diplôme est si réussi à être
prof d'anglais au japon il va pouvoir le
réussir à avoir son diplôme
alors si c'est un petit char
laver des frères et des soeurs et sa
maman il l'a perdue et des humains ils
le trouvent dans son jardin alors il
récupère l élève mais j'y fais n'importe
quoi et à auxerre qui est le principal
personnage de l'histoire on a choisi
d'emmener les veines quoique dans le
coup et a beaucoup demandé m quand même
pas si une accumulation sans coup
beaucoup à celle héros de dragon
pour au début on a commencé à baisser
une journée à l'initiative de plusieurs
partenaires le club manga mais également
la bibliothèque municipale et la
cyberbase du bas de la rivière et en
ateliers ont été proposés ainsi que des
contes autour du manga dans notre
quartier on n'a pas ce qui est l'espace
réglé on est venu avec toute leur classe
et des enfants donc vous dire on est
venu manger dans cet espace là et la
journée c'est continuez donc cet après
midi avec des remises de prix avec le
club manga du collège rêver que nous a
présenté donc un kamishibaï et donc on
vient juste terminée par un pot de
l'amitié il choisit de faire le clown
manga parce que j'aimais bien et mangas
et madame dia - six mois inspiré c'est
une très bonne des commandes
documentaliste très gentil et
on a beaucoup travaillé sur explosé
combien de feurs donc les mangas et
c'était un peu stressant au début mais
on a réussi donc je voulais remercier
tout le monde qui était venir merci
madame guillaume euros merci madame
delphine et tout loupé la manga puisque
que le manga déjà parce que moi je lis
déjà plusieurs mangas comme naruto
dragon ball z
c'est un univers qui m'a intéressé bien
moi je suis pas vraiment très coloré
patrol de colorier plus les dessins les
membres du club qui ont travaillé
pratiquement une année sur les mandats
ont présenté des kamishibaï dans le
texte dans quels délais un kamishibaï
toute une histoire inspirée des contes
et des mangas pierre bonnet le pédiatre
en voilà
s'appelle un bout de taille dans lequel
on place à michel
les autres cas les shebab ont utilisé
cette histoire ces histoires transport
pour attirer la clientèle vers eux comme
ça les écouler leurs stocks et au moment
le plus propice pour que le suspense qui
s'arrêter comme ça après les
clients convenait pour savoir la suite
une belle journée donc dans un espace
magnifique qui se prête à tous les
rassemblements et plus encore à la
découverte de pratiques lointaine qui
pourtant font désormais partie du
quotidien des nombres